our next guest brought love and light
into our lives on rupaul's drag race
where i get to be a judge i know olive
your daughter loves that show
olive loves it unfortunately olivia lux
her time
came to an end on the show last week
let's look at her first moments
entering the workroom lux
be a lady tonight
i'm olivia lux and i like to light up a
room
whenever i walk into a space i consider
olivia lux as
that diva but that like
really nice diva like diana ross and the
supremes
please welcome olivia luck
hey everyone hi olivia
thank you so much for coming on the show
i mean it's all in the name olivia lux
may i
ask what the origin story is to your
most
fabulous name olivia comes from olivia
pope from scandal a
fierce black leading woman i love kerry
washington so much and lux comes from
the latin word for
for light i like to think that olivia
lights up the stage
and lights up every single room she
walks into i was wondering if you have a
little beauty diy
hack for us today so i have here with me
a very sheer
uh powder i love to put this powder
over my makeup after i'm done with it
before i do setting spray
i think it's really important that when
you're using powders and stuff with
makeup
that you're also knocking back in some
color into the skin
some warmth and another thing that i do
to add radiance into my skin
um after i put on all the makeup is in
my setting spray
i put glitter i know it's a little weird
but i put bronze and gold glitters into
my setting spray
so when i um apply it it's nice and
radiant
and you can just feel the light and the
and the shimmer yeah i have to say the
result
is incredible because you're getting
glitter
not from your craft store you're getting
it from beauty company so
the mic is really fine you're not going
to look like a craft project
it really does just add a little bit of
hint and light pick up it's a really
amazing tip i had
never heard about it before you and i
were like really and then she tried it
and we were like oh
really it worked it's magical y'all and
um it's funny i heard that it's like diy
episode yeah um
and when you have new things a lot of
times there's pesky
little stickers like barcodes on your
on your things when you get them in yeah
um so my roommate
actually taught me another diy trick
that isn't beauty but i definitely think
it's a life hack
um so to get the stickers off of
products if it's pesky you put
peanut butter on the sticker i know
it's wild try it at home
it is so magical you put it on there i
think it's because the peanut oils
i think that that might be what it is
i mean that's optional uh i haven't
tried that i think that's another diy
tip i'm trying this immediately and
reporting back
olivia thank you these are the kind of
hacks we need to know about and
just thank you so much for coming on the
show today yeah and
i just have to tell you it has been a
pleasure to watch you all season long on
rupaul's drag race season 13. i cannot
wait to see
what you do next olivia i'm so excited
thank y'all for having me
this is so much fun rupaul's drag race
airs friday night